l espoir de sortie de crise réside
aujourd'hui sur la vaccination
en russie vladimir poutine appelle la
population à recevoir l'injection antico
vide d'un geste nécessaire selon le
président russe qui s'est exprimé à la
télévision
il espère une immunité avant l'été mais
à ce jour seuls 4 % de la population
russe a été vaccinée la correspondance à
moscou d'antoine clairon la situation
face à la propagation du coronavirus se
stabilise tels sont les mots du premier
ministre russe michail me justine
prononcé ce matin lors d'une réunion
avec ses vice-premiers ministres
le nombre de décès quotidiens locaux
vides est d'ailleurs passé sous la barre
des 300 et ce pour la première fois
depuis novembre 2020
la stratégie adoptée pour combattre
cette pandémie et on le sait la
vaccination de masse afin de développer
une immunité collective et là il faut
écouter les professionnels cela a déjà
été dit après limité de la population
sera formé afin d'y arriver il faudra qu
environ 70% de la population adulte soit
vaccinée si cela va au même rythme que
maintenant je pense que nous atteindrons
les devrions atteindre ce chiffre
à la fin de l'été et au copaxone et pour
ce faire la russie dispose de trois
vaccins trois vaccins aussi fiable les
uns que les autres d'après vladimir
poutine il est nécessaire que chaque
personne prenne une telle décision font
elles mêmes et qu'ils consultent un
médecin et un spécialiste rythme et en
gros vous pouvez vous faire vacciner par
n'importe quel vaccin n'importe lequel
d'entre eux ils sont au niveau des
meilleurs sérum au monde n'ont pas moins
- temps qu'un certain d'achat à mon avis
en ce qui concerne le novalis ans ils
n'ont aucune contre indication
je sais avec certitude que des personnes
atteintes de maladies chroniques graves
se font vacciner et se sentent très bien
je ne sais pas au moins je n'ai pas
d'informations sur les effets
secondaires graves que pourrait
provoquer une trois axes 1 enregistrée
nous les avons donc conçu autant ils
sont efficaces et viables et sue lyon
nenê diogène et ibiza passionnés on en a
donc encore une fois la confirmation la
vaccination du plus grand nombre
reste la priorité des autorités ce qui
constitue un défi en soi étant donné
la défiance de la population russe face
à la vaccination en général
et comme de nombreux autres dirigeants
vladimir poutine s'est donc fait
vacciner la semaine dernière afin de
montrer l'exemple